[Music]
[Applause]
hi and welcome to episode number 116 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I mock Mandal and I'm here with my
colleague Melanie Warrick Melanie how
are you doing today I'm good you're good
I'm good that's good I'm in the studio
you're in the studio you haven't left me
today back from New York any day now
you'll leave me it's fine back from New
York I had a really good time at the fat
star conference yeah talked a lot about
fairness accountability and transparency
and we'll put a link back into our show
notes everybody we use interested in
checking out all the videos are captured
but anyways we're here to talk about
other things today we're going to
actually interview two of our solution
architects specifically the director of
solution architect team and one of the
solution architects that's on the team
to learn about all the things around
solution architects yo yeah we're
talking to miles and grace later on but
first we always have our cool things the
week and then we also have our question
of the week our question of the week to
tease everybody is how do I get a docker
image into mini Kubb mini cube i mini
cube yeah okay anyway in mini cube
without uploading it to an external
registry and then downloading it all
over again is there an easy way to do
this locally that question of course
coming from mark because he's working a
lot in the space right now let's start
with our cool things of the week yeah
there's a bunch of cool things this week
why don't we start with the fact that
cloud IOT core is now generally
available if you're not familiar with
cloud IOT core it is our fully managed
service to help securely connect and
manage your IOT devices at scale that's
all the buzzwords yes that's all the
buzzwords and apparently it miss general
releases incorporating a few new
features you can now publish data
streams from the IOT core protocol
bridge to multiple cloud pub/sub topics
and you can simplify deployments so
check it out yeah and we have a whole
bunch of device partners an application
partners as well so if there are
particular devices or application
platforms that you need better use check
those out we'll have a list there in the
blog post another thing we have for the
week is that Jupiter lab is apparently
ready and beta and accessible for all
users and Jupiter lab is actually coming
out of the Jupiter group and Jupiter is
based originally off of this notebook
that's become very
popular in the data science space in
particular this notebook allows users to
create and share documents that combine
live code with narrative text
mathematical equations visualizations
interactive controls and other output
sources it's really a useful tool and so
they've built Jupiter lab and Jupiter
lab in particular is something that
they're using as this interactive
development environment for working with
notebooks so it is able to integrate
with text editors terminals data file
viewers and other custom components and
allow you to basically do a more
comprehensive workflow check it out it's
really interesting and we're gonna
actually have a link where you can find
out more information and figure out how
to install it awesome for another one we
announced that Google Cloud spanner can
now be used as a vault storage back-end
if you're not familiar with hash ECOT
vault it's a really cool open-source
tool for basically in managing secrets
and it's very popular across Google
cloud platform as well as kubernetes
this is kind of cool because spanner is
a great way to have high availability
across multiple regions and have that as
a back-end so it enables a few things on
vault that are kind of neat in terms of
like transactional support as well
enterprise-grade security basically it
uses the same security as cloud spanner
which is amazing
and it's also supported by Google which
is also nice if you want to get started
should download and install the latest
version of hash a core vault zero point
nine point four apparently at time of
reading good to know and then the last
thing we want to mention four cool
things of the week and this is something
I know especially comes straight from
Mark's heart on the game of the world
there's a blog post on how to handle
mutating JSON schemas and streaming
pipeline with Square Enix yeah so this
is not a cool written looks like in
conjunction with Square Enix their game
studio they make a lot of really cool
games Final Fantasy sx near automata
I could go on for a while yeah but they
talk about basically how they ingest
a wide variety of JSON data across a
wide variety of Studios because they're
made up of a variety of studios and how
do they handle different Jason schemas
coming through and how to deal with
mutating Jason and how to handle it when
you have multiple basically people who
are ingesting data through this pipeline
it's a really cute article that's also
written in the style of first you have
like a hero and then you have a
character and then they have to defeat a
boss and the bosses the mutating Jason
and it's really adorable and
a good diagram of the pipeline as well
as they have a link at the bottom for
those who want to check out more common
usage patterns for cloud dataflow great
ok mark well I think it's time for us to
go talk with Miles and grace let's do it
today I am ecstatic to re welcome
someone who has been on a podcast before
but also somebody new we have miles Ward
director of solutions for Google cloud
as well as grace Mollison cloud solution
architects coming to join us today to
talk all about solution architects and
Google cloud how are you both doing
miles how you doing hi I'm doing super
super good it is a sunny day and the
clouds are out
excellent grace how are you doing I
didn't manage to mess up your name by
the way no I'm fine date so you thought
you over here we did the London so I'm
looking forward to having my hot
chocolate before I go debate very nice
excellent so we really want to talk to
you both about solution architects at
Google what does that role what do you
all do before we do that why don't you
tell us a little bit about who you both
are miles why don't you go first sure
I'm an electric tuba player and that got
suckered into helping with technology
and my gig over the last four years here
at Google has been engaging with our
biggest opportunities our most
sophisticated customers and helping them
figure out how to solve problems with
Google's tech I've been doing public
cloud for about a decade and spent a lot
of cycles helping some pretty high
visibility high high criticality
projects come to market
I spend a bunch of time working together
with the the kind of all-star team in
the obama for america reelection group
so that that team built some pretty
incredible technology 1800 virtual
machines 200 applications from scratch
in six months with all volunteers a
whole bunch of fun project worked out of
that and here at Google we've been
helping enterprises and startups and
small businesses figure out how to use
our toys use our toys cool and yourself
grace I've also been working with a
public cloud for a shot about ten years
as well my started off doing consultancy
with the MC at that point then I moved
to work with AWS where I was a Solutions
Architect there and then I ended up at
Google and I do some architecture work
working with us
and with our wonderful CD team and I
also spent a lot of time teaching the
rest of my team how to speak the Queen's
English good on you know something I can
definitely get behind so it's there
something miles that's required to be an
essay to be a really good essay we don't
limit to ten years it's not a bad start
the the cloud from a technology
standpoint is is growing and changing
very very rapidly so that actually the
number one skill we're looking for is a
long history in learning new stuff that
platform is evolving so quickly that
we've got to be able to keep pace I mean
none of us were thinking at all about
machine learning four years ago and now
half of the team is working in machine
learning Tekken making sure that
customers are able to capture
opportunity there so it's it's a pretty
fun gig the question actually was it's a
tuba player part something that's a
required part practical answer to you
know what is involved in being an SI yes
we do not limit our definition of weird
to including only tuba but that's gonna
do require weird so that kind of
structure is is really important in our
kind of evaluation and in coming folks
we've got a truly unusual motley crew
when we go out as a group it's a bit of
funny-looking zine so you've got people
from you know the guy who deployed third
of the servers behind World of Warcraft
and Dan has code that's running in the
arm of the Mars Curiosity rover and
we've got folks that rendered the movies
that everybody watched and folks that
have helped the banks process trillions
of transactions it's a WoW it's a funky
group of folks yeah and you've also
forgot Myles about John whose birthday
is every single day not many teams have
that that's right we have a person who
has a birthday every day and it really
makes sure that we're in a constantly
celebratory mood excellent okay so apart
from being interesting and strange at a
high level like what is the solution
to take that so yeah I think I think I
think grace you should take this because
miles is not we're scaling function Abbi
basically I spend every day of my my
working week scale you myself out of a
job so what that really means is the
fact that I will I will work with
customers or net new and problems things
that our documentation may not quite
have clear so people can see the logical
flow particularly when you're blending a
number of products and I document that
we get it published and I move on to the
next thing or I help people to actually
understand if the documentation isn't as
clear as it should be how they should be
interpreting it at nice cool so if
people I know I've seen solutions that
have been posted on like the
cloud.google.com website huh is that
your team miles is that what you do yeah
100% of the material that's a called a
google.com slash solutions is stuff
someone from our team built and a bunch
of the technical documentation around
the business comes from or is inspired
by a lot of the path-breaking work that
we do together with customers and that's
that's exactly the model grace is right
she she sort of maybe under asserts the
degree to which a lot of this comes from
direct engagement with customers like
grace is working with some of our
biggest hardest opportunities and when
they get to a place where they're
scratching their heads and we're
scratching our heads we sort of dive in
together to find the answer right
whether that's there's currently no
floating IP addresses available as a
part of GCE networking so how do you do
a software application that depends on
floating IP addresses we do the research
and we dive in with customers and do a
bunch of experiments the result is a
white paper that says here are the four
different ways you can work around that
problem that we've seen actually work
and that kind of gap filling and
enablement you can sort of fake it and
just sort of yeah this probably how that
would work but when you do it together
with customers it's real and tested and
tested by somebody who really needs the
answer to work so it helps us make sure
that the guidance would give is
something that's that's valuable you've
talked to a couple of the examples but
can you guys talk a little bit more
about the kind of customers and who the
customers are that you're
working with sure I can I can provide a
couple of fun examples we spent a lot of
cycles with one of the biggest banks in
the world HSBC in Grace's backyard we've
been working through helping them apply
machine learning and our data platform
so tools like data flow and data prep to
be able to digest the bank's data and
perform better projections better
analysis so one example that'd be easy
is like fraud detection there's however
many millions of dollars a day of
fraudulent charges that come through
that Bank and I have to do the guess and
go yeah I bet you every owed Bank has
that problem too so we work together
with this specific bank to help them
build a fraud detection model machine
learning model on top of cloud machine
learning engine using tensorflow
and the output of that is higher
performance than the current systems
that they have so they're implementing
it in production and we're going through
and doing the work to figure out can we
turn this into a pattern a solution that
other companies would implement can we
make it that pattern easy enough that
our product teams start to go hey maybe
that should be a product it's all part
of this lifecycle of discovering value
for customers and helping them get
pieces built like another easy example
you know there was a pretty big
emergency project with the folks at
Evernote they wanted to be able to move
all of their systems over to Google
Cloud in less than 90 days right so this
is three petabytes of customer data you
know hundreds of independent systems and
we have a professional services team
that works really hard to enable and do
the the grunt work of picking these
pieces up but there were specific
implementation questions how do I get a
shard in my sequel to replicate over the
wire how do I make it so that we're able
to tune for improved performance using
Google's superfast solid-state disk
those kinds of questions when there's a
blocker when there's something we don't
know how to do folks from my team so
that one was Brad came in and Brad's
feet came in and asked a bunch of
questions and was able to get down to a
best practices implementation for their
my sequel system that now we're applying
to other customers so that's the model
is find these big customers help them
unpack and and then teach the rest and
how long do these types of engagements
last so it's all
now we have a lot of conversations where
customers are really just looking for
that first piece of guidance right where
maybe a little a little better version
of Google let me google that for you
right oh you know maybe we couldn't find
the doc before but here's where it is or
you know this is generally this kind of
best practice that you want some
customers have hundreds of problems
thousands and they can keep us busy and
they continue to push platform so we
have some places where people have been
involved for a long time but generally
we're looking at anywhere from a
super-dense phone call to a couple hours
on a whiteboard to you a week of kind of
a proof of concept or a first
implementation so we've had some
previous podcast episodes on talking to
people who like for example like CES
customer engineers sort of account
management side of things how do you all
differ from those sort of roles passes
over to grace grace hasn't said anything
Aloha we don't actually own any accounts
as such they tend to be owned by the
customer engineers and the account
managers and essentially the customer
and there's gatekeeper us they they they
request our assistance which is how it
works and we also work alongside PSO as
well so we kind of have their backs if
you like to a certain extent is the way
I like to see it so as an example and
and what's PSO sorry as an example the
other day you mentioned one of the
solutions that I wrote the GCP policies
one of the CEO of a large American
company saw that passed it to their
customer and then the customer says it
would be really good if we could talk to
the people who worked on that so they
got myself in the project manager who
helped me and work on some of that work
and we were on a call with them
yesterday
so I'm discussing how they should
approach things and just talk them
through how to use those papers so
that's great cuz often don't get a
chance once it's been published to
actually then talk to people who write
the beginning of even looking at the
documentation so that was really great
experience no how do people actually
reach out to you so as I said that that
was that was an example where the C II
found the blog post and then the Custis
showed cents the custom and the customer
said it'd be great we could talk to you
it tends to be for Mike me personally in
the UK it tends to be people
she doubts me either by our project
managers particularly the area that I
focus on with security and I am in
Europe and the time zones I tend to be
kind of a first call as working
alongside some of our specialists ee so
we have some CES who focus on particular
areas so we've got some security focused
MCS as well and I work alongside those
so there's different avenues to get
through to us okay and are there certain
types of projects that you get asked to
do that you would say or not a good fit
for solution architecture role we're no
good at making sandwiches you have to
say sudo first and we really like what
we don't want to do is something we've
are done like that's the core is we were
trying to be at the front edge of
identifying how customers can use our
platform in new ways grace can go and
engage with that customer who's thinking
through how to apply policies to their
their business but she's gonna bring CES
with and they're gonna take a bunch of
notes and hopefully the next time the
next customer comes they don't have to
bring grace along the C he can handle it
that's where grace was talking about
with the scaling function right so it's
not that there is any individual thing
we don't want to do we just don't want
to do it ten times I said to flip that
around it's worth pointing out I guess
if you go to the the slash solutions
page on cloud.google.com these are not
solutions that were written in isolation
these are written for customers to be
implemented like rubber meets the road
type stuff yes yeah exactly like there
are so many production customers that
sit on top of those patterns that are
following our guidance that's the way
that we're all supposed to work do you
normally engage we'd say a certain size
of customer or is it a broad range or a
variety of industries how does that how
does that sort of pan out what happens
because I happen to work a lot on the
onboarding security side and the
complexities you see when to work with
large strategic customers I just tend to
work with a lot larger a lot more gnarly
enterprise-e types that we've got
guidance for the sort of start ups and
green fields but because they're starts
and green fields I haven't got the
existing infrared
to the cloud without basically break
your business the cool thing with our
team is there's a lot of diversity in
the background and skills you know cloud
platforms almost 60 something products
at this point plus you have to sort of
know about all the hardware and software
that there's ever been on the planet so
it's impossible to have coverage so like
if grace spends a bunch of cycles on
identity and security and kind of
enterprise setups we have folks that
have a bunch of gaming background or a
bunch of media background or have spent
a whole bunch of cycles with retail
companies right so those types of groups
have different problems and we work took
resolve issues at any size so the
threshold for us is not looking at like
you know who's the very biggest customer
possible but which is a customer that is
ready to work together with us so that
we can learn as much as possible
sometimes those are little tiny
companies that are out in the middle of
breaking path so it's it's all over that
miles with such a wide range of skills
how did you find the people that are on
your team how did you build this team
about 78% referrals this is the point so
there's a there's a phrase dorks can
smell their own that are better old
friends and that have been working on
these kinds of problems for a while and
we take the interviewing and recruiting
process really seriously when this group
gets together it's it's just a bunch of
buddies on the couch it's a super fun
way to way to connect and hang out and
and a lot of peers who have really seen
high scale stuff and high stakes stuff
so we're getting better and better every
day at finding folks that have the right
attitude and have the right history of
learning even though they may be from a
new set of skills that it's helping us
cover new areas and that expansion is
happening all the time
and are you hiring yeah we're absolutely
hiring we've got a whole bunch of spots
amia Japan that's a global team because
here in the u.s. right if you're in
Mountain View doing a start-up and you
want to talk to you an engineer at
Google you have a lot of different
options and for a single product too
often in cases you can get access to
over time if you're doing interesting
stuff and pushing the boundaries you can
get access to engineers that are working
on the actual products
in Singapore you know we have folks in
tel-aviv and Korea and Japan and you
know Stockholm now and each of those
places it's harder to get access to an
engineer so solutions architects also
serve as this technical point of
escalation inside of the sales process
so that engineers in our remote
territories have somebody that's at
their level to talk with and a lot of
that ends up being us supporting the
product management and product
development exercise how would I know
I'm a potential solution architect we
hire on a Google system that they have a
whole bunch of internal labels for this
stuff but the same kinds of operations
people that get hired for the Google sre
roles tend to be a good fit for us
more of the questions about cloud have
to do with how I make this thing work
and keep it working then then how do I
develop a new application on top we have
great teams in developer relations and
others that are that are helping our
developer friends this teams tends to
spend more time in operations land it
also tends to look for people who have a
background in hands-on operations of
either large scaled on-premise
infrastructure so like we have an
engineer who used to run operations for
concur and that's all data center based
but it's the same kinds of problems
they're trying to solve as our cloud
customers so there's a lot of customer
empathy that's possible as a result of
that so another dimension and that is
Google cloud is it's something that you
boss around the code and it's not the
environment where you know if somebody's
just exceptionally good at pointing and
clicking inside of system center or
vCenter or something like that that
they're they're gonna be the right fit
our customers are asking us to help them
automate to help them instrument to help
them turn into a dynamic environment
what has been static and hard to manage
so we do have a coding bar we need
people to be able to help not just
explain solutions but develop them so
this should segue nicely hopefully so
I'm curious I mean you both work with a
lot of customers directed to you grace
are you seeing any particular trends in
terms of the help that customers are
needing or the sort of things that
they're doing
yeah so as I said that's that's how I've
been able to produce some of the work
I've done because I actually work very
closely with customers and you start
seeing a pattern once you start seeing
those patterns you can actually then
convert them into guides and documents
and tutorials and reference
architectures so as an example every
customer wants to understand how they
can actually map their job their
functional roles to IM roles that's
that's something that you just need to
learn how to do at the beginning so you
know i just say to people step away from
the keyboard
think about your planning map those
roles to your IM roles and then you can
start implementing it folks also want to
understand how to automate things as
well so that's a very common question is
like are they hybrid multi-cloud do they
want to use OSS solution like terraform
or do they if they're all into GCP then
maybe they use deployment manager says
help with them make those sorts of
decisions you know and looking at the
skill sets they've got already and just
bringing them on the journey really
grace what do you enjoy most about what
the work you do I love the fact that
every week I've learned something new I
also love the fact that you know I'm
asked to work with customers you know so
I have a lot of respect for our own
CII's particularly because they've got a
hard job and I love working with them
they're very collaborative and you know
I get up every day really enthused about
work I know when we both met before this
I'd asked you would there be anything
else you would do other than being a
solution architect and I said tell you
is it really really hard to think of
another role that fits me personally and
and the stuff I like to do and I think
you know if I was put on the spot maybe
I'd look at doing something into
Deverell or maybe working within the PM
orc I mean they've said they're the two
roles that would fit because I've I used
to do a C type role at AWS so I know how
hard that is I've done that and it's
like evolving and at the moment I really
enjoy this job and I can't see anything
that rivals it you like everything but
miles right yeah I know he's terrible
we there's this phrase that you know
there are kind of two kinds of people in
the world folks that are entropy
creators and folks that are entropy
destroyers I think you can sort of make
a quick guess as to which side of that
dividing line oh I know you've published
a lot of solutions and maybe you can't
necessarily name names but that's been
the most interesting solution that
you've had to provide for a customer
grace we're just talking you're wanting
to go ahead so ironically enough it's
pretty much in the first six months that
I joined I was helping work with the I
am team with regardons helping them get
it to GA we had no real knowledge at the
moment how how was this going to work
how were customers going to go to
interface with it so that that was a lot
of them talking to a lot of big
customers who were able to give us some
input some people like Spotify for
example and provided a lot of input
there and then it evolved so the the
latest set of Doc's I would say were the
ones that I actually enjoyed the most
because it took some of that early work
and then it was blending it with lots of
different things so I looked at billing
and I looked at the networking I mean I
looked at you know the cloud resource
manager and as I had all of these all of
these bits and I've got to actually
figure out a logical path to make it
clear and easy for our customers you
know so it was in the beginning and the
most recent stuff for the two things
I've really enjoyed working on I think
so I've done consulting in my past and I
know one of the biggest challenges we
were always up against was scope creep
and trying to keep you know especially
customers within the bounds of
expectations and realities of time I
assume that's one of your challenges
that you're against in terms of this
roll it how do you usually work with
that I'll say that because of the
definition of the team is relatively
clear that when a customer is blocked
either at the beginning I don't think
this is possible on cloud or at the end
hey you people said this was possible on
cloud when they get blocked and we don't
know how to solve that problem that's
exactly when solutions architects get
involved and similarly when they are
unblocked and they can appear to be able
to continue to move without our support
and assistance that's when we go away so
far the scope creep has not been from
you know the individual projects like
genuinely people ask for relatively
specific things because that's the
current long poem the tent that they
need resolved but there's certainly a
very small number of us and a very large
number of customers and so I think the
actual creep is more about can we put
you in every customer everywhere and
that that's relatively complicated
because there's hundreds of thousands of
them and there's dozens us so the the
creep is the creep is internal it sounds
like a constant juggling of prioritizing
and what are some other challenges that
you were working with in terms of of
managing this team miles my big job is
it is an easy one it's helping our folks
continue to learn the new hard bits it's
real easy to I know everybody does this
you find a place where you have
expertise you get relied on for that
expertise by others but the world of
technology changes so rapidly that any
amount of real experience and depth in a
given area has value for about a decade
so we have some of our folks on our team
that had been here for half that long so
all of a sudden you're going well you're
halfway to having the experience that
you add at the beginning be not
worthwhile maybe you should learn some
new stuff so there's a whole bunch of
training and you know some of that is
autodidact people dive into whole new
pieces some of it is stuff that we help
people through in a lot of cases you
know kind of following the solutions
architect model that's training that we
go build that's the best we know how to
learn so we didn't have GCP 101 like the
most basic onboarding training materials
to teach people how this stuff worked
and grace had just started so she wrote
it and know now we have a training class
right like that's that was her way of
figuring out how to run all this stuff
that's that's why we like her well and
then off of the learning point grace
what are some things that you're excited
to learn about in the future in the near
future
so I'm actually pivoting now to spend
some more time with the data left loss
prevention API and I'm working very
closely with the PM there so I'm really
enjoying that because it's a really fun
product and it's so underrated it's just
really very powerful and obviously with
all the things regarding PII and
making sure that you can stop sensitive
data getting out early it's just a key
tool that's fine and I'm also gonna be
doing some work with the stackdriver
team as well so it's still in the same
area but there's just you know new
things all the time
cool so we're running out of time here
but before we wrap up is there anything
that either of you wanna plug or mention
or talked about before we we finish
things up here miles we're in the middle
of building some new and I'm pretty
excited about some new things to do at
our big events next and the Global
Summit Series
those are great opportunities to connect
with solutions architects essays are
always there and it's a great way to get
maybe the 15-minute version of an
engagement where we can get on our big
whiteboard that's got all the
architecture icons and systems you can
come and hang out with us and we'll help
figure out how to solve the problem that
you've got and so one of the things that
we're working real hard on now is kind
of an interactive environment for that
kind of solutioning a little bit of a
game so there'll be more MORE about that
as it gets out and launched and done
we're still fighting over the name but
generally I think the events series this
year is going to be a lot of fun nice
grace we're hiring basically I'd like to
personally see more females join the
Solutions Architect team but to be
honest it was the same problem at my
previous role it's a fun job and you
know you should give it a chance
that would be my plea because you know I
really enjoy it and I'm sure others
would too well great thank you again
we're really it's great to talk to both
of you grace thanks for hanging in there
so late for us too to get you on the
call that's okay
awesome yeah thank you to you both and I
really appreciate you both taking this
home ok thank you awesome
thanks a bunch thanks again miles and
grace for coming on the podcast that was
wonderful to hear about what solution
architects do fun stuff you guys
actually do on the side and yeah I'm
really glad you guys were able to join
us yeah it was a really great episode
super happy to hear again from people
who help support our customers and how
they can interact with them if you are a
customer and distress what they were
saying in the podcast they are hiring so
you should reach out all right Marc let
me ask you the question of the week how
do I get at a docker image and
mini queue but without uploading it to
an external registry and then
downloading it all over again is there
an easier way to do this locally yeah so
this is near and dear to my heart being
kubernetes so meaning cube is a really
nice tool for running a kubernetes
cluster locally so usually what it does
is it'll run a small virtual machine
that has kubernetes installed as a
single node installation and that's
really nice
the interesting thing is when you're
like oh I built my image locally how do
I get it into the VM so that that
criminate is cluster can see it there's
a couple of interesting ways you can do
it one of which is you can actually
build inside mini cube there's ways of
doing that you can actually mount your
code inside the VM it's good that works
but it means you might necessarily be
double building stuff there's other
options where I've seen people who have
installed their own docker registry
inside mini cube so they can push to
that and then sort of pull down locally
from there but there's an even easier
way which I really like
which works if you're running a Linux
terminal of any kind which is you can
actually pipe the docker image into mini
cube which is really cool so if you use
mini cube and I'll put a link to the
exact command but if you've used me in
cube if you say meaning cube docker
environment it'll set the dock or
environments up so the doctor knows oh
I'm not running locally I'm gonna push
all my stuff there and there are two
commands duck or save and duck or load
so duck or save will take a image and
put it into a file or put into it like
output stream and duck or load can take
a file and import it or take it from the
input stream so we basically just pipe
it so you do a docker save with the
image you want pipe it into an eval of
the duck environment and then docker
load and then it pushes it right in if
you don't need a local registry you can
build locally it actually it's really
nice I like it a lot nice well thanks
for that mark and one other question do
we have a new sound going on yeah
starting last week thanks to our
wonderful editors who put together our
wonderful new intro and outro music
apparently we've had a few folks who've
noticed it so thanks for for giving us a
shout out and letting us know that
you've been hearing it and then last but
not least I'm gonna mention if you want
to contact us you can email us at hello
at GCP podcast comm you can reach to us
on twitter at GCP podcast you can also
reach out to us on google plus at plus
GCP podcast as reddit which is also GCP
podcast and on slack you can just
request an invite to the google cloud
slack community and join hashtag pod
has channel cool alright alright mark
going anywhere in the next few weeks all
the events - all about GDC still which
is coming up when which is coming up
it's the 19th of March off the top of my
head I'm pretty sure that's right
fantastic
we're gonna have a full day Google
developer day with a bunch of different
people speaking there's a booth sessions
or having meet the experts the booth
that'll be fun we're sponsoring some
parties I'll talk about those probably
next week grab all that kind of good
stuff so we'll definitely be around
reach out come say hi I'd love to meet
you if you're there no mentions for me
the for this week now in the next couple
of weeks yeah now right now that's fair
enough
more to come later cool all right well
Melanie thank you very much for joining
me yet again on the podcast this week
thank you Mark and thank you all for
listening and we'll see you all next
week
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]